Okay.
[inaudible]
I really like,
it's like it's more than it is.
It's like what they were afraid of was
pirate radio where everyone can have
their own radio station.
You know,
they wanted to control that,
regulate that.
I can't remember now,
but now the podcast is way more pervasive
than even just regular prior pirate
pirate radio because you can listen
to it when there's no radio signal.
You can listen to her iPhone,
iPad or an iPhone rather and,
and,
and keep that shit.
You know in the gym you could,
you could listen to it on planes
so you could listen to it.
You know,
you could have an iPod and take it with
you in the bathroom if you want to.
You can go swimming with those fucking,
they have waterproof iPod containers.
You can listen to that
shit while you're swimming.
You know,
there you need a reality show.
That's what you need to,
you're a Weirdo.
You're an interesting motherfucker.
People would like to,
I like to watch you have one.
I know,
but I'm saying you need one on TV.
Someone needs to snatch that shut
up and just follow you around with
professional cameras and shit.
I mean,
the thing that you're doing,
I'm mastering the system is cool
and it's letting people know,
oh no budget.
He rolled budget,
you know,
there's a little budget.
I am paying someone to put it together,
but it's like minimal shit.
You know what I mean?
If there was some kind of budget,
it would be nice where I can have someone,
when I can just tell someone
to do anything and like a,
like a producer dude and I go,
I want this.
I want that.
Once I get to the point where I have a
guide that will just do everything that I
say and I could afford a Pam or
someone else's paying him once,
then everything's going to go right
because there's so much shit I want to do.
I just don't have time
to do everything now.
Right.
Every day is packed with
shit and I'm not even trying.
Just everyday is just so busy.
Yeah.
Well the good thing is you're
doing everything you wanted to.
That's what you know,
like the key to a happy life is,
even though you're busy,
you're still busy with
things or you enjoy.
Yeah.
I'm not complaining at all.
Matt,
every day,
every day.
I love my last name and
I'm not complaining.
I'm just really busy.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's,
it's sometimes it's hard to,
you know,
I got calmed myself down
and counseled myself.
Dude,
you're lucky.
Motherfuckers smile.
You should be laughing right now.
You should be enjoying
the moment right now.
What the fuck are you doing?
Stressing them out this
and stressing about that.
Forget about that.
I got it every day.
I got myself stripe stress though.
So what keeps you pushing forward?
That's what makes you,
what motivates you?
That same drive,
even though sometimes a fresh jar,
it's all this energy that you built
up to try to become successful.
It's very hard to become successful and
be really laid back at the same time.
And a lot of times people
just don't push far enough.
It's just you've got to learn
when to chill out and when not to.
But in order to really push forward,
you gotta be pretty intense,
you know,
to really get shit done.
There's no way.
It just,
it's hard to be laid back
and to get shit done.
You know,
you've got to get got to get her up,
you know,
just crazy man.
Yeah.
Crazy shit.
It's all good stuff though.
What's going on with you Brian?
What's the latest?
Get tired.
Why are you tired?
It's doing a lot of work.
Work.
I'm really busy.
Like it's like you're in better shape.
I've been working out.
No,
it's fine.
He's been fucking and eating bananas.
Look at them.
I see you haven't.
This is what he does.
Fucking go.
Reladyne fucking eat bananas.
Fuck three times in the drink.
Sparkling Water and he eats bananas and
he fucks in every now and then it goes
to Starbucks,
the gorilla diet.
I've been making big commercial.
I've been reading the
Kalyan whatever diet,
Paleo Sally and she a little commercial
parody then you and Dunkin shoot.
That would be fucking great.
Your Diet.
It's just soda water.
Like Perrier bananas and Fucking Dude.
That'd be a funny video.
You could have champagne if you,
this is what you,
this is your workout routine.
This is what you do.
Show it like you gotta you
gotta spend 10 minutes Doggy,
10 minutes fucking not
an aerobic activity.
Some sort of serious fucking
that shit that's your,
that's your was roam around alone.
She's gotta be on top and she's got
to keep moving and you've got at least
thrust the hips,
you know what I mean?
You can't just lay that out and
you gotta go home gotta work.
You gotta grab her ass too.
And you know what
you're working on lasting longer.
So the girl benefits too.
So you'd get more girls,
they want to come back
because you're on this diet,
they want to come back,
go back like you're a rider.
You know what I mean?
You're a fucking machine.
You go 45 minutes on that bitch was the
last time you fucked for 45 minutes and
last night did you do it
well or did you cry a lot?
So you think people would on,
did you cry it off after you come
once and then you in my question like,
like five minutes later and it's like
you don't really have to come again,
but your dick still hard.
So that's great.
We'll the shot like you might be,
this is a,
you're in a new relationship right now.
We should stipulate that Brian May be
starting out with a pace that he can't
keep up.
That's true.
It would a woman who complained that
she's only you only fucking her because
you're on this fucking diet.
You know,
you're only fucking me cause
it's not the fucking day.
You wouldn't be fucking me.
You should cut.
Stop talking to that girl.
She sounds like Eddie just sounded like
don't talk to a girl like that.
Okay.
Those bitches are crazy.
So,
uh,
this weekend we've got Joey Diaz next
excited to do the next podcast with Joey
video.
Mother fucker off.
This motherfucker were high and he
starts talking about earthquakes and was
going to happen because
Brian's cast retarded
fucking earthquake.
If you're catching the
sweetness cats in the world,
that's very chilled as cats.
If they're acting kind of jumpy.
Something's going on.
We both been here before.
They're not uncomfortable with us.
That'd be a little slim is covered.
The big ones.
I had San Francisco waiting for his ass.
That's the one that's stuck in geologists.
No so much.
Why didn't you make a phone call to Japan?
Because
Japan is just the eyes now.
We've already hit fucking earthquake.
Locale.
What's the flex and mash was
back to smoking cigarettes.
Although I'm getting dizzy already busy.
Really busy.
Well,
I just smoke one just to
get the party started.
Site.
It gets applied.
He signed.
Yeah.
Make sure the loans are attack.
Gives you a jumping jack site.
I got to make sure that these
fucking lungs are working.
What are it?
Go to the gym four and do all this shit.
If I can't puff.
I got a test of it is sort of
like weightlifting for your lungs.
Cigarettes.
There's nothing better for you.
I see Brian's dirty laundry now.
This is where it folds to
when he wants to get crazy.
Go skateboarding Simpson's style around
the neighborhood that were rubbing her.
Fuck.
See more to your door.
No beef,
no more.
Where did that come from?
You couldn't smoke in a
fucking weed to get that line
to your door.
See wants some of these names through
without seeing more to your door.
No beef.
No more Nigga.
Feel the rush.
Dangerous.
The more weed I smoked
the profit on more danger.
Stop.
That's what I'm talking about it.
By the way.
Another way.
100% you people like I
dropped it before Havana.
Nocturne,
PJ English.
He got another book out
that's killing motherfuckers.
Gonna go right to the New
York Times number one,
savage city,
New York City,
1970s with the brothers and everything.
They got a picture of fucking Tupacs
mother and there was a black panther is
carrying a fucking military gun.
Life fit doubt 58 damn.
This book,
very good book.
I read like two chapters.
I can't read any more bucks,
man.
I got no more space.
I got to know him.
A space on my hard drive.
I don't want to delete any information.
I really think about that.
Now I'm going to look at the news.
TV shows like some new DVD,
like all those looking at the waking dead,
you know,
walking into whatever the fuck it is.
They had a DVD out.
I'm like,
man,
I heard it was a good series.
I don't know room for that shit.
I have no room in my brain,
man.
I don't even remember Dexter.
I remember I liked the first season.
I don't remember anything more about it.
I just am deleting shit
left and right man.
I got no room and I'm
talking about which are,
you know what I'm saying?
Between the weed and cats,
the fucking podcast life.
You got to delete some times.
I just started taking this stuff called
five HTP is supposed to increase your
mental foundation.
Who?
Vx 70 what's the word?
Webinar.
So he's got some new shit.
That shit that the,
I'm Lewis.
I Carla,
we could call it neuro one.
I have a bowl that cheddar
smoked.
That's like supplements
just for the burden.
You don't want to smoke.
It
just jumps folks.
Let's do this.
All Shit.
Okay,
cool.
Okay.
Really here from the Joe
Rogan experience comedy,
but this,
we were talking about the Angel
Salazar write down as they call it,
the meltdown of a rock.
Just Angel Salazar plates
cheat sheet Scarface.
Very funny guys.
Been around for a while,
but it's the last of the real ball.
He comes,
you got Tracy Morgan
got a couple of people.
The Angel is it,
so they've got two shows on a Friday and
a Saturday night was the first show of
standing ovation.
No worries.
He goes to the old and he goes,
listen,
I want take a nap in between shows.
I this is all right.
Go in the green room.
I'll wake up.
I quoting the 10 called the 10 pay job.
No Angel,
10 o'clock age or no age or 10 after angel
take home and you take the screws off
the door and the door knob.
It pushed the door and this angel is,
I'll go away.
I'm like makeup on when like red
shirt coming out of his nose.
This all pasty.
Some of y'all to talk to angel.
Oh Dean.
So he picked him up by his ankles.
Leash,
wakes him up and he's like
Angel and angel saying,
what man,
Tony Montana,
what the fuck I did?
The first show is like,
agent,
you got to do another show.
And he's like,
what show are you talking about?
Where am I?
Because Angel,
you got to do a show.
So he got it.
He got aids on of dressing.
You put an angel and his
little costume born in the USA.
Angel from,
if he goes up there,
this is the song.
He has not changed as accurate.
20 years,
not even a peep.
He has not even had an attack.
He still comes up the board to the USA.
That's all came out 1980
fucking four he understand me.
So he's up there and he's,
he's forgetting the lyrics to
his own song that he wrote.
More than that you are saying,
you know,
five minutes go by.
He's up there and fucking habit believe
Tony Montana Chino was just such a novel
that he was the original Scarface.
He still has blown all this shit.
Finally as a chicken,
the first row were big
tennies with a family.
He sits on her lap and started kissing
the attendees and people start booing
him.
So he gets back and off stage.
It was like,
fuck you guys,
I take you all to hell.
And they went to sit down and dog.
He's just like this.
He sat down,
Joe Rogan take y'all to help
pass time,
take bus things had to get my money back.
And every time they did
they took all his blocks.
They took him and put him in his jeep
and they locked the door inside the hotel
room.
The next day they got a
call at six in the morning.
He was like,
well hoppy last night.
They're like,
angel,
Bro,
you had a meltdown.
He goes like,
no,
no.
The owner gave you a roofie
cause he didn't want to pay me.
That's what happened.
The older put a roof for your bike
trick cause he didn't want a baby.
I know.
No one knows what he did.
I called Angel soursop top down.
How long ago was that?
Three,
four months ago.
Wow.
Angel sales.
Rowan warrior for a long time.
When you were there doing the road,
like he's doing the road and you,
you don't really have a
place to live or if you do,
you're never there.
He just go from one spot to
the next going and Dylan,
whatever the fuck anybody's got.
We got heroin.
Do you got math?
You got a comb
but drug dealers,
clover club.
Wait for
no fucking way,
man.
He's like,
he has this little old gray
of rooms where they just wait.
They just wait for him.
He comes to town.
It's fucking nuts.
We're on our way to the Portland.
Helium was to helium's affiliate Portland.
Never been to Portland.
[inaudible]
I swoop as a jet jet again.
Don't want to keep it down in there,
which I'll cry about.
Can't believe I going to deal with this.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
which you took that
drug.
Oh,
Katy Perry song.
First of all,
Portland is the shit.
This town is awesome.
This is one of the coolest,
most positive,
most fun crowds we've ever had.
Never has anyone handed me
more weed in any town anywhere.
It's not even a close second.
Portland dominated in the
weed passing out department,
not even close in.
The crowds are cool as fuck and what
we're seeing for sure this weekend is that
we're getting podcast fans now.
It's like almost all podcast fans
who saw that last week in Seattle.
Although joy could attend
because of previous warrants,
the probably that we're going
to get done and taken care of.
Well we're going to contract out little
representatives and see what the fuck is
going down.
But Portland was the shit man.
This is a on a shortlist man.
As far as like bad ass cool cities for me,
this is on a short list.
There's like Austin,
Texas.
Portland is right the fuck up
there with Austin in my opinion.
Don't you think people are cool as fuck
here and the podcast crowds or this is a
different crowd man.
We're getting a different crowd now.
We're getting there.
All fucking nice man.
This is one thing that
waitresses say and they've,
oh,
they've just been saying
this for a long time,
but even more so now,
like today day they kept going on
about how friendly the people know.
That to me is almost more
satisfying than anything else.
The fact they're loving the show,
the fact they're coming
to having a great time,
that's all great.
But what really makes me feel good
is that I hear that they're nice.
I hear the crowds now.
One problem.
No,
look at the shape and where
you guys smoke me the fuck out.
This was you guys teaching.
You're telling me the deck this weekend.
It was just a great ratios,
great grounds.
And we just discussed the staff at the
club is world fucking class and I mean
no,
they left us alone.
That's why the shows us so great.
There was no drama.
So thank you very much.
And who was crazy?
It's how many people like
came up to us and said,
uh,
like,
you know,
you really make it my day so much better.
I'm just driving.
I'm doing these like hard jobs or manual
labor jobs and it just an enjoyable,
yeah.
Makes they love it.
Right?
How many people did you talk to?
There's like,
you're changing my life.
He changed the way we think you changed.
You know,
I mean,
we keep hearing that same thing.
It's that same theme over and over again.
You know,
I'm like,
I'm hanging out with you guys
and I'm thinking like you guys,
I'm,
I'm thinking positive and I'm trying to
enjoy my time here and surround myself
with friends who are likeminded.
You know,
it's the most important
thing you could do.
We be positive.
Have Fun,
enjoy your time.
Be Fun to be around surrounding yourself
with other people that are the same
way.
And every day you laughing like us.
Joe Does every day.
Oh,
are we laughing?
Every day we're laughing.
I was laughing.
I couldn't even laugh anymore.
What were the crowds?
The crowds were what?
You make me laugh.
I make you laugh.
So I mean,
I can't,
I really am blown away.
Wasted.
There was so I had a drink.
What did you think,
dude?
Because this was the first
time when you got on stage,
you've got some roars dude.
It was like breaks.
Yeah,
it was.
I can't see your face
on deal a little crazy.
It was so amazing.
It was.
It was insane.
How awesome.
Like the crowd reminded me a lot of Texas
just like really happy to see comedy
like a lot of people came out
for after the show was just like,
you know,
we never have experienced
comedy like this before.
We never were into stand
up comedy or anything.
This is all new to us.
Well Gee,
that's one of the unique
things about this talent.
Joey can tell you know
the history of this place.
I used to come down here in the late
nineties and it was Harvey's at Harvey's
was a good club,
but there's too many restrictions.
You can't curse.
So just a certain amount of comic.
Gilead dirty comic had
one week of dirty comedy.
It was James,
Edwin,
Doug Stanhope and me.
That's it.
That's what that was like
crazy
putting the drugs or be a magician.
So when the helium opened,
they brought a different
type of comic up here,
which opened up the door for a lot of
different comics that wouldn't be allowed
to come up here because of the budget
restrictions or Harvey's or whatnot.
And I'll tell you man,
one of the reasons why I hate trial was
because of the club's fucking with you.
This club and the city was outrageous.
How they are in Philly
too,
you know fairly is incredible.
Outrageous.
Yeah.
I'm happy I can't thank you Paul.
Oh please.
Thank you for the 55
fucking joints and smoking.
Uh,
it'd be sick again Tuesday cause
I can't smoke with people pipes.
I smoke where everybody,
if they were that nice I have to
make it out of Portland and did,
we just got done smoking like
eight bulls and 17 joints.
There was one where I'm like
holding two joints on one goal.
It was like being in the eighth grade
that was looking at his phone and she'll
be in the eight grade.
And the first thing I was telling Joel,
there was 60 people,
40 people,
you know,
like a six groups of like six people
and we were smoking and the cop stopped
looking at us and just kept fucking
driving like he thought that restaurant,
well I've,
I felt like the vibes of the crowd,
they fell to me like a real,
like a real strong potheads.
It was like a strong pothead crowd.
Like that might've been like 90% stoners.
Right.
And it was so great because
everybody was cool as fuck.
Everyone said no,
we grow out here.
We don't have the stores.
We just grow our super gross.
And apparently they don't give a fuck.
They're not trying to force a shit at all.
Like I get guilt you're we'd known carries
crazy because the club manager came
up to me 1130 last night.
He goes,
guys,
I just want to warn you,
if you guys did this on Friday,
Thursday,
tomorrow's will be completely nuts.
And then went to eat with you guys.
Then I went up to my room and I started
thinking about what he said and they
grew up in my head like a fucking,
we'd actually put too much pressure on
me at five 30 I was already dressed and
showered.
That's how the crazy game,
because my emotions come
out when I'd be standing up.
When I see people in
the first show tonight,
usually it's a Christian crowd on
Saturday night and some people have
babysitters.
These people are fucking nuts.
Thinking up the ride,
they were eating their finger back.
They took the wrong,
she only wrote me and said,
I went out there to watch him for 10
minutes and I was listening to you and I
could feel these people,
they were in with you.
It was a movie.
You'll watch a movie.
It was something even sitting
on the side of this place.
So thank you bro.
Fucking stone work with me
is a bad ass town.
So in short town is
unquestionably the shit.
He was one of the best place
we've ever been performed.
One of the short lists of where
to move when their pocket upsets.
Portland just shot right
the fuck up the charts.
This is how fucking bad ass
Portlanders whomever they have.
They have these solar powered
compactor is solar panels on the top.
The sunlight powers this fucking thing.
You throw the trash in there and it
smashes it up into a nice usable cube,
which if you were so inclined,
perhaps you could use
for the construction.
Very biodegradable house.
Either way,
this is
bad ass shit.
Portland's ahead of the curve.
Yes,
no.